hello and welcome everyone hope you're
having a great day and welcome to m
coding where we try to get just a little
bit better at programming every episode
let's just jump into it today and start
off with a question for you
suppose you're given two or more
dictionaries containing corresponding
data
by corresponding data i mean they share
the same set of keys
in this case the keys are some channel
ids for some of my favorite youtube
channels and the values are names and
subscriber counts of those channels
take a moment and let me know in the
comments below how you would iterate
over these corresponding dictionaries
while you're doing that let me motivate
this example a little bit
because the first question you might
have might be why do we have the names
and sub counts stored in separate
dictionaries
you might be expecting something more
structured like this
in this example we've defined a class
that stores the id name and sub count of
a channel
and then we have this structured data of
channel data stored in a list
if you got this data from a web api this
is what you might be expecting to get
back an aggregate of structured data
types that each contain many different
types of data
you can then have a dictionary of ids to
the channels they correspond to
and then the preferred way to loop is to
loop over the items of that dictionary
this is certainly a common case but it's
not the only case for instance if the
names came from one api like the youtube
data api but the subscriber counts came
from a different api like the analytics
api then you could very well end up with
two separate data structures that have
the same keys
and that's how we end up with the
situation from before
whether you got these pieces of data
from separate sources and your goal is
to combine them or whether it just makes
more sense in the context of your
program to keep them separate and you
just want to loop over both of them the
question remains how should you loop
over the corresponding data
here's one way to do it it works but
it's not the best way loop over the
channel ids from the names then use the
channel id to pull out the name and sub
count
but the first thing i want to note is
this is actually an anti-pattern of for
loops
whenever you loop over the keys of a
dictionary and then the first thing you
do is get out the value corresponding to
that key you should instead prefer to
loop over the items of that dictionary
this is going to be slightly more
efficient because when you loop over
items you don't have to compute the hash
of the keys this method is also fine and
it works but it's still not quite what i
would like the names and sub counts are
supposed to have corresponding data but
if there was a missing subscriber count
i would get a key error
whereas if there was a missing name i
would silently just loop over less data
this kind of asymmetry can cause very
subtle bugs
additionally the code just looks a
little bit asymmetric and that can cause
it to be a little bit harder for people
to read here i'm looping over names why
not loop over sub counts instead
even though they share kind of equal
purpose in this iteration i had to pick
one of them to go first so while it
works this is still not quite what i'm
looking for to get a better feel for
what i am looking for let's take
inspiration from a very similar example
suppose that instead of dictionaries
these data were stored in corresponding
lists
in that case the simple and
straightforward way to do it is to use
the built-in zip
and as of python 3.10 i could even use
the strict flag to ensure that all the
lists have the same length
i think this is a very clear great way
to do it for lists so how do we zip
dictionaries we can't just use zip
itself because zip is going to loop over
the keys of dictionaries
we could try to zip corresponding items
but there's a lot of problems with this
approach we end up repeating the id
field
we now need extra parens
and we're actually depending on the fact
that the keys were inserted into the
dictionaries in the same order
as of python37 dictionary iteration
order is guaranteed to be insertion
order
but since these dictionaries came from
potentially separate sources we can't
really assume that the keys were
inserted in the same order even if we
know that they have the same keys what i
really want is to be able to write
something like this
i want a dictionary version of zip
and when i loop over it i get out the
key and then value value value for each
of the corresponding dictionaries
to me this api is simple and
straightforward just like zip
only problem is there is no dict zip
it's not a built-in like zip and it's
not part of the intertools library
either
but we're all programmers here if we
want it we can write it ourselves
so let's write it take in the
dictionaries we're going to make this
function a generator so let's just throw
in a yield so that we have that mindset
if we weren't passing any dictionaries
then we just stop
i personally like the strictness to be
built in so let's do a length check
then we go ahead and loop over
corresponding keys in the most efficient
way that we can
that means using the items method of the
zeroth dictionary and then just grabbing
out the rest of the values from the
other dictionaries in a comprehension
here i'm using a generator comprehension
to get all the values then the star is
used to unpack all the values so that
the result is a tuple so all in all we
have a tuple of the key first value and
then the rest of the values and that's
all there is to it
now we can loop over corresponding
dictionaries in a straightforward way
and all the asymmetry that we had before
is hidden inside the implementation
there are a few other things that i want
to say about this implementation though
first off this is a prime example of
something that really should be
implemented in c in python we're forced
to use brackets in order to get the
corresponding values for the keys every
time we do this this involves computing
the hash of the key but the hash of the
key is the same for every dictionary so
why recompute it
this is from the c python source code
it's in the file dict object dot c which
defines the implementation of a
dictionary
in particular in c we can use this get
item known hash function
this function is special built for
getting a key out of a dictionary when
you already know the hash
so our dictionary zip is a perfect
example of a place where we could save a
lot of computation time by removing the
need to recompute a hash function
this is something i could say more about
in a future video if you're interested
but i claim that if we did this using
the c api we could get away with not
computing the hash function at all for
any key
there's also one other hidden usability
issue in this implementation
look what happens if i try to use
autocomplete on one of these entries say
the channel id
i get
nothing useful
not everyone depends on autocomplete but
having it there is a huge win for most
developers and the way we wrote our
implementation is not amenable to
autocomplete of course if this was part
of the standard library we wouldn't have
to worry about this it would be taken
care of but a little tip when you try to
implement these things in one of your
own code bases you can help autocomplete
work better by using type hints
unfortunately if you think about what
the signature of this function should be
python's type hinting system does not
yet support it there's an early draft of
a pep to fix this in 312 or 313 but for
now here's a quick fix the quick fix in
this case is to provide typing overloads
for the most common use cases i'd say
that zipping one two or three
dictionaries together are the most
common cases so make all the type
variables you need and then just provide
overloads for each of those cases we
actually don't even use dictionaries any
mapping will do so here's an overload
that takes in two mappings they share
the same key type but they can have
different value types then i'll return
an iterator of tuples of the common key
value 1 and value 2. let's go back down
to our example and see how the
autocomplete works now
here we are again and let's see what it
does perfect this time i'm getting
string autocomplete suggestions for the
string key
and for the sub count which is an
integer we're getting in suggestions
finally don't be afraid to go wild and
to find ways of iterating that work for
your code base maybe you just want to
loop over common elements of a
dictionary like a sql interjoin or maybe
you want to loop over a union of keys
like an outer join and provide a fill
value
in the right circumstances providing
these functions can actually vastly
improve the readability of your code and
that's what i recommend you do think
about the ways that you iterate is there
anything that you do often by hand that
you could just make a function for if so
do it anyway thanks for watching that's
all i've got thank you to my patrons and
donors and i'll see you in the next one
as always don't forget to slap that like
button an odd number of times